qué es lo que pasaba cuando tomábamos la
derivada con respecto a x la siguiente
expresión x elevado a la n 1 entre n 1 +
una constante bueno y claro estoy
hablando cuando n es distinto de menos 1
entonces lo voy a poner aquí en es
distinto de menos 1 porque si fuera
menos 1 aquí tendremos menos uno más uno
que es cero y eso sería indefinido no
podemos dividir entre cero y bueno para
resolver este enigma voy a recordar la
regla de la potencia de la derivada que
decía toma a la potencia y baja la
multiplicando a la equis entonces me va
a quedar la potencia que es n 1 que a su
vez esto multiplica la equis y después a
la potencia o no este no es el mismo
color de hecho es [ __ ] el mismo color
es la parte más pesada de todo esto aquí
está entonces a n1 lo multiplicamos por
equis y después le bajamos 1 la potencia
en uno menos uno me da n y todo esto
queda dividido entre n más uno que
teníamos aquí abajo y después tenemos la
derivada de una constante pero cómo
antes no cambia cuando cambia x la
constante es constante entonces su
derivada era 0 y ahora si n 1 / n 1 son
dos cosas iguales y por lo tanto se
cancelan y me da de resultado 1 entonces
este y éste me dan 1 y en resumidas
cuentas si em es distinto de menos 1
toda esta derivada me da x a la n la
derivada de esta expresión me da como
resultado simplificado x la n iv bueno
una vez que ya tenemos esto entonces
quien es la anti derivada déjenme
ponerlo con otro color para que sea más
visible la anti derivada de x elevado a
la n diferencial de x y recuerden que
esta anotación es la anotación para la
anti derivada va a tomar más sentido
cuando veamos integrales definidas pero
ahora sí cuál va a ser la función que al
derivar la me va a dar x la n iv
recuerden que esto tomaba el nombre de
integral indefinida o dicho en palabras
coloquiales cuál es la función que al
derivar la me va a dar x a la n iv pues
lógicamente me vas a decir qué
esto que tenemos aquí arriba x elevado
en la n 1 entre n más uno más una
constante y esta constante puede ser
cualquier número puede ser 123 pi un
millón por lo tanto esta constante puede
ser lo que tú quieras y me quedaría de
resultado x elevado a la n-1 entre ende
más uno más una constante y aquí ya
tenemos la integral visto como la
operación contraria a la regla de la
potencia de la derivada y ojo hay que
recordar que el cne tienen que ser
distinto de menos 1 porque si fuera
menos 1 pues esta expresión no estuviera
definida recuerden que no podemos
dividir entre 0 por eso hay que
especificar que n tiene que ser distinto
menos 1 y bueno pues vamos a estrenar
esta nueva fórmula que acabamos de
obtener es decir vamos hacer algunos
problemas que tengan que ver con la anti
derivada de la regla de la potencia para
la derivada y el primer ejercicio que me
voy a tomar es este de verde que dice la
integral de 5x de x y bueno lo único que
hay que hacer es darnos cuenta que n en
este caso vale 5 en es la potencia de la
equis y por lo tanto hay que
incrementarla en 1
51 y dividirlo entre ese mismo número
entre 5 + 1 por lo tanto es x elevado a
las 5 más 1 entre 51 más una constante
de integración recuerden que esta
constante puede ser cualquier número y
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que xe a los
6 entre 6 más la constante de
integración y ya están obtuvimos el
resultado del primer ejercicio de este
tipo de integrales y ustedes pueden
derivar x las 6 entre 6 más una
constante y van a ver que van a obtener
x las 5 ahora otro ejercicio que parezca
ser un poco más difícil tengo la
integral de 5 por equis elevado a la
menos 2 diferencial de x y bueno lo
primero que voy a hacer es sacar la
constante yo sé que esto no lo ha
probado rigurosamente sin embargo en la
derivada pasaba lo mismo
las constantes las podíamos sacar afuera
de la derivada y pues en la integral
también pasa lo mismo
la constante va a salir y me queda cinco
veces la integral de x elevado a la
menos 2 diferencial de x 5 que
multiplica a la integral de x elevado a
la menos 2
x y ahora voy a utilizar esta fórmula
que estamos usando es decir 5 veces de
la expresión x elevada a la menos 2 hay
que sumarle 1 el exponente es decir
menos 2 más 1 y dividirlo entre menos 2
más 1 y sumarle la constante de
integración más una constante de
integración
y ahora vamos a simplificarlo me queda 5
que multiplica a x a la menos dos más
uno que es menos uno debo dos y pagó
unos chivos debiendo uno entre menos dos
más uno que es menos uno más la
constante de integración y esto es igual
a cinco veces que multiplica a menos x
elevada menos uno más la constante
integración lo único que hice fue
dividido entre menos uno y esto es lo
mismo distribuyendo el 5 que menos 5 por
x la menos 15 veces una constante y aquí
ojo 5 veces una constante arbitraria
pues es exactamente lo mismo que otra
constante por lo tanto voy a borrar este
5cm es más podemos ponerle 15 1 c 1 c
uno ya está constante que es cinco veces
uno llamarla se al final es otra
constante arbitraria y aquí lo tienen la
respuesta es menos 5 que multiplica a x
elevado al menos uno más una constante
hemos acabado y te invito a que tú
dérives esta expresión para que obtengas
el resultado 5 que multiplica a x
elevado a la menos 2